[Musique]
le centre est fermé au public
alors le centre vie se déplace chez vous
verra la maison propose la location
durant 48 heures de casques de réalité
virtuelle livré à votre domicile pour
découvrir des courts métrages en 360°
primés dans les plus grands festivals la
planète deux programmations sont eux
faire découvrir le monde
kirin neuf films pour voyager sans
quitter son salon ou encore récit
imaginaire qui met l'accent sur les
films d'animation l'inventivité des
créateurs personnellement j'ai vécu des
expériences avec certains oeuvrent en
réalité virtuelle qui m'ont profondément
ému j'ai pleuré avec un casque de
réalité virtuelle sur la tête
on peut raconter une tonnes d'histoires
différentes on peut raconter des
histoires en animation on peut offrir du
documentaire on peut offrir des oeuvres
qui sont par exemple sans parole mais
qui sont aussi des histoires on a vu
dans ce médium on a vu le futur on a vu
les possibilités immenses qu'offre la
réalité virtuelle et on a eu envie de
faire partie de cette aventure
ce qui m'a plu dans l'expérience verra
la maison sékou pas avant car j'avais
testé la réalité virtuelle c'est dans
des contextes de galeries d'art ou dans
des contextes je me disais seulement
quelques minutes
j'avais l'impression qu'on était
davantage du côté du cabinet de
curiosités que du côté d'une véritable
forme d'art le fait de pouvoir le tester
à la maison de l'immerger durant
plusieurs heures
ça m'a permis de comprendre que les
créateurs peuvent vraiment raconter
d'histoires qu'on ne pourrait pas à
raconter au cinéma grâce à cette
technologie de la réalité virtuelle toi
le filet puis mais qu'est ce que t'as
pas si ton expérience
ben moi j'ai eu accès la programmation
numéro 1 de 20 heures à la maison à
seulement extraordinaire le tour de
force je pense de nous faire vivre le
moment
un film magnifique sur la station
spatiale internationale fasciné par
l'espace belge été jetés dans l'espace
les deux pieds dans le vide j'ai vu la
planète terre ça nous fait immensément
réfléchir film sur les vrais soucis on a
l'impression de gravir l'everest ont
manqué d'oxygène donc c'est vraiment une
chance parce qu'il faut le voir pour le
croire c'est un peu ça à défaut de
pouvoir voyager dans la vraie vie on
vous pouvoir voyager virtuellement grâce
au centre fille
ici n'est bien les centres chartier lui
fait depuis mai radio canada montréal